powers
are not a gift
but a curse
let's catch up on Black Adam as The Fall
season cools things down theaters are
heating up with the release of Black
Adam so we're gonna break down
everything that you need to know about
that let's be honest trying to figure
out when a DC movie is coming out is
like chasing a moving Target but at this
point I think it's safe to say that the
Black Adam theatrical release date of
October 21st is good to go and of course
we know that Dwayne Johnson AKA The Rock
after much prodding from fans and plenty
of work on his end is finally taking the
mantle of Black Adam it's like we all
get to finally smell what he's been
cooking up for the last eight years
Black Adam is an anti-hero of sorts who
was enslaved for 5000 years for pursuing
Justice his own way in a place called
condak before being Unleashed in modern
times Black Adam was directed by xiaomi
koyette Sarah mostly known for directing
horror films like House of Wax and the
shallows plus a few Liam Neeson
Thrillers but that background is
actually pretty perfect given black
Adam's complicated status is someone who
can be good but also very bad kinda like
the Rock's previous career is one of the
most famous wrestler of all time and now
here's proof that I literally sat nine
inches away from his face and asked him
about it because Black Adam you know
straddles that line of good and bad in a
similar way that you did in your
wrestling days turning from a face to a
heel a few times did you close to that
wrestling character at all or tap into
it to sort of get that balance of good
and bad for blackout oh that's
interesting yes it wasn't my lead foot
when thinking about the character and
standing him up on its feet and
breathing life into him uh but no doubt
my experience as a pro wrestler where I
would uh continuously straddle the line
of good and bad and eventually it got to
a place in that world of pro wrestling
where uh it was just an accepted thing
that when the character of The Rock
comes out uh he'll do things that might
be questionable but at the end of the
day everyone in the arena understood why
and that's how they left so same thing
very similar to Black Adam you may not
agree with uh his philosophy but at the
end you do understand why so there may
or may not be a people's eyebrow in this
movie I actually asked him that too so
you'll have to watch the rest of the
interview to find out what he says along
with getting to know my new best friend
Dwayne in this movie we will also be
introduced to the idea of a group called
The Justice Society of America the
original members in the comics included
Green Lantern and the Flash along with
Dr Fate who will be showing up in this
film played by James Bond himself Pierce
Brosnan people are so stoked on Dr Faye
that some fans are already calling for a
solo film and the leader of JSA is
Carter Hall AKA Hawkman an archaeologist
who is The Reincarnation of the Egyptian
prince who originally enslaved Black
Adam now he's played by Aldous Hodge in
this movie and let's just say putting on
the Hawkman suit was a pretty darn big
deal for him when you saw the trailer
there's this epic moment where we see
Hawkman Wings yeah what was it like for
you to see yourself suited up for the
first time oh it was amazing I mean for
me I was waiting on the wings you know
I've been wearing that suit for months
and I was like oh
baby we better be ready because uh you
know you can only imagine sort of the
grandiose nature of what it is you're
you're sitting there first of all the
day that we all got to set we all saw
each other in our suits we were like oh
it's real it's like cool you know what I
mean it's happening but then when you
see it all put together you see the
trailer that's when your imagination
completely explodes and you know when
you're working on it that this is
something truly incredible but this is
something that you work on it and then
you watch it you really get to be a fan
you get to be a kid again because your
mind is really just going all crazy with
what you've actually accomplished the
the magnitude of what you accomplish is
so huge and it is really truly one of
those dream come true type of deals so
for me
first time I saw it full out I was just
I was kind of floored speechless taken
back because now you're a part of
something that is truly in its Essence
and it's full Essence uh
something that has the power and will
and can change the the the notion of
perception perspective ideas belief
representation this is what the value of
the work is that we do art in its purest
form we get to influence and Inspire and
that's something that you know this
inspires true imagination that choosing
these inspires belief and inspires
ambition to go push for those dreams so
when you see that costume for me it's
more than just putting on a suit yeah
it's putting on dreams you know what I
mean that was so beautifully said I mean
those are some beautiful words I would
have been like Peter Pan you can fly hi
also part of the JSA and Black Adam is
Maxine hunkle AKA Cyclone played by
quintessence Swindle and whose powers
include controlling wind and generating
sound not to be confused with Psy the
mascot for the Iowa State Cyclones who
have no powers to speak of another JS
Sayer coming to the big screen in this
one is Adam Smasher played by Noah
centineo who can manipulate his own size
and strength meaning that he can grow
really big like really really big here's
what he had to say about it Noah when I
watched a trailer the first thing I
wanted to ask you was what is it like
being bigger than the rock yeah did
Kevin Hart has to borrow your power
that's so good yeah well first and
foremost I started calling Dwayne the
pebble
College
oh my God oh my God
ah that was funny don't ever call him
that though and if that seems like a lot
of potential good guys and or
anti-heroes well it's worth noting that
marwin kinzari is slated to play the big
bad Ishmael Greger AKA sabak who is the
reason that Black Adam may have to team
up with the JSA to try and take him down
beyond that and getting a bit of an
origin story of sorts for Black Adam and
the others we don't really know much
else about how the story is going to
play out but we do know that Dwayne is
hinted at the appearance of Superman in
this film on numerous occasions at DC
fandom he said that quote the hierarchy
of power in the DC Universe is about to
change and when he was asked to
Comic-Con this year Black Adam will ever
Battle Superman he said quote it depends
on who plays him
before a world of Heroes
and villains
one power
ruled it all
Black Adam
[Music]